or any do in this video is see how we
can approximate limits graphically and
using tables in the future we're also
going to be able to learn techniques
where we're going to be able to directly
figure out exactly what this limit is
but for now let's think about how to
approximate it and it'll give a little
build our intuition for even what is
limit actually is so we want to know the
limit as X approaches 2 of X to the 3rd
minus 2x squared over 3x minus 6
now the first thing you might want to
check out is well what is this
expression equal to when X is exactly
equal to 2 and we could do that by
substituting X with 2 so it'll be 2 to
the 3rd power minus 2 times 2 squared
over 3 times 2 minus 6
well this numerator over here this is 8
minus 2 times 4 minus 8 so that's going
to be equal to 0 and then the
denominator over here is 6 minus 6 well
that's 0 and we end up in the
indeterminate form right over here so
this expression is not defined for x
equals 2 but we can think about what is
the expression approach as X approaches
2 and first let's think about it
visually so if we were to graph it and I
graph this on the sight desmos which has
a nice graphing calculator you see the
curve y equals this expression right
over here so this is the curve of y is
equal to let me do that in a darker
color this is equal to Y is equal to X
to the 3rd minus 2x squared over 3x
minus 6 and you can see at least
everywhere where I've shown it here and
it's actually true it's defined
everywhere except for when X is equal to
2 and that's why we have this little gap
over here showing that it is not defined
and so what I want to do is I want to
approximate well as X gets closer and
closer to either from lower values of 2
or from larger values of 2 what is the
value of this expression or the value of
this funk
approaching and at this level of zoom it
looks like it's approaching this value
right over here so as X gets closer and
closer to two it looks like our function
is getting closer and closer to that
value there regardless of which
direction we are approaching from and so
just approximating it visually right
over here let's see this is 0 this is 2
this is 1 right over here this would be
1.5 at this level of zoom it looks like
it's about 1.3 or 1.4 so 1.3 or 1.4
let's zoom in a little bit more and if
you have access to a graphing calculator
or you go to a website like desmos or
Wolfram Alpha you can you can zoom in
further and further on this graph so I
encourage you to try that out yourself
or we'll do it with other graphs so
let's zoom in even more so once again
we're not defined at x equals 2 but here
we get a slightly better read let's see
this is 1 this is 2 the value that we
are approaching as X gets closer and
closer to 2 we're getting our values
getting closer and closer to that right
over there and if we look at what Y
value that is let's see if this is this
is split into 1 2 3 4 5 so this is 1.2
right over here this is 1.4 right over
here so it looks like it's between so
this would be 1 point 3 right over there
so it's a little bit more than 1.3 so
little more than 1.3 so approximately
1.3 let me now do that in a lighter
color so it's approximately 1.3
something it looks like let's do them in
even more to see if we can get even a
better approximation so now once again
we're approaching that same value we're
not defined at x equals 2 but as we are
approaching x equals 2 let's see let me
get a darker color so it would be right
around there and this is to see this is
1 1.1 1.2 1.3 1.4 1
five so once again it looks like it's
about one point if I were to just base
it off of this looks like it's about one
point three three three or one point
three four so I'd say approximately one
point three three so approximately one
point three three if I were it looks
like it might be approaching one and
one-third but we don't know for sure
where we get remember when you're trying
to figure out a limit from a graph the
best you can really do here is just
approximate try to eyeball well the
closer word X gets to two it looks like
this function is approaching this value
right over here now another technique
which tends to be a little bit more
precise is to try to approximate this
limit numerically so let's do that so
let me get rid of these graphs here we
already got a sense of of what the
graphs can do for us they got us to a
about one point three three but now
let's try to do it numerically so I'm
going to set up a table here and I
encourage you to do the same and so on
this column I'll have my X and on this
column I'm gonna say well what is the
expression X minus two x squared over
three X minus six equals and we know
that when X is exactly equal to two that
this thing right over here isn't defined
let's see what happens as we approach 2
so let's see at what happens when we're
at one point nine or one point nine nine
I'll do one point nine nine also one
point nine nine nine and we can also see
from the other direction we could say
well what happens when we approach from
at two point zero zero one and see if we
are getting if this at both of these
values seem to be approaching something
and so this is approaching it from from
lower values of X and then we could say
this is approaching it from higher
values of X we could say two point one
right over here so let me get a
calculator out and evaluate these and I
encourage you to do the same get a
calculator out and see if you can
evaluate these things all right so let's
see if we can evaluate it when x equals
one point nine
it's going to be 1.9 to the third power
minus two times two times one point nine
squared one point nine squares is equal
to so we get that value and then we're
going to divide by divided by we get
divided by three times one point nine
minus six and that's going to be equal
to looks like it's about one point two
oh three so I'll just write
approximately one point two zero three
now let's try it with a much closer
value of x so that was just one point
nine now let's go to one point nine nine
nine so once again we're going to have
one point nine nine nine to the third
power and then minus two times open
parenthesis one point nine nine nine
squared close the parenthesis is equal
to so that's my numerator and then my
denominator so / / and now open
parenthesis three times one point nine
nine nine minus six close my parenthesis
is equal to one point three three two so
this is interesting so approximately one
point three three two so numerically I'm
see I seem to be approaching that same
value or close that same value that I
was approaching graphically and we can
also do it from values of x greater than
two
let me get my calculator back and I'll
do some of it and I encourage you to
finish this up on your own and you can
even try one point nine nine nine nine
nine nine to see what it actually is
approaching so for example if I wanted
to try to point one so that would be two
point one to the third power
-
two times open parenthesis two point one
squared and then closed parenthesis is
equal to that's my numerator divided by
open parenthesis three times two point
one minus six close parenthesis that's
my denominator and I get one point four
seven so approximately one point four
seven so now you could think I'm getting
closer and closer to from values larger
than two let's see if we seem to be
approaching the same value so now it's
getting even closer to two two point
zero one and I'll do this one and then
I'll leave it up to you to think to see
if you can get even more precise so two
point actually let's get super precise
let's well let's do let's do three zeros
here two point zero zero zero one to the
third power minus two times open
parenthesis two point zero zero zero one
so we're getting really close squared
close parenthesis is equal to so that's
my numerator divided by open parenthesis
three times two point zero zero zero one
minus six this is my denominator is
equal to notice we're getting closer and
closer and closer to one and one third
one point three three three three now
five so I'll say approximately one point
three three three and this is now for
this is actually for two point zero zero
zero one so it does indeed look like we
are approaching one point three three
three three three three or close to it
looks like we are approaching one and
one-third but once again this is these
are just approximations both through the
table or graphically if you want to find
the exact value of the limit there are
other techniques we're going to explore
those techniques in future videos